today is one of the saddest days in my
lifetime it seems like a bad it's like a
bad dream she just want to wake up from
it was a nightmare
Dwyane Wade in tears over the sudden
death of his friend Kobe Bryant Moses
all over the place these are the moments
when you ask why heart those goes out to
Toby's family Oh Gigi this is a sad day
there's no way around it
Kobe and his 13 year old daughter Gianna
who many called Gigi were among nine
lives lost in a tragic helicopter crash
on Sunday in Calabasas California we
have so many moments that he's given us
I'm so thankful for those moments I'm
thankful for those moments there's one
of my favorite players and I got to have
a relationship a friendship
Dwayne changed his profile picture to
Kobe and Gigi and has been sharing his
favorite moments throughout the years
when I came in to meet I chase him
that's what chased I wanted to be
respected by him and was I've reached
that level I knew I did something so
Kobe Thank You Man thank you for all the
memories did we got a lot of good ones
and these tears that we cry on we're
gonna miss you
it's not gonna go it's not leaving today
we from now a month from now a year from
now forever forever miss you man
you are legend your icon your father
your husband just son your brother your
friend thank you for being much man I
love you brother
fans have gathered in front of the
Staples Center where the Lakers play to
mourn the loss I mean it just doesn't
feel real he was a legend it's crazy too
that it happens today the Grammys here
at Staples Center we spent you know more
than a decade lighting this place up so
but someone that Kobe he's bigger than
an icon you know so it's as much as that
he's gone is he's he's forever he's
forever the Grammys were held in the
Lakers home on Sunday night we're all
feeling crazy sadness right now because
earlier today Los Angeles America and
the whole wide world lost a hero and
we're literally standing here
heartbroken in the house that Kobe
Bryant built coppice jerseys were lit up
and on full display inside the arena
the NBA announced on Monday that they
will postpone the Lakers verse Clippers
game that was scheduled for Tuesday
night Kobe was such a great man living
Oz said it best not only was he a legend
in sports but he was a legend as a man
as a father and just a great role model
and it's a it's a very sad tragic day
and and bittersweet for all of us here
at the Grammys
you
[Music]